[Música]
escala en París Ahí va para la
Bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio Francia internacional y France 24
Hoy les hablamos de la Eco agricultura y
la etnoveterinaria en Ecuador con motivo
de un premio el premio benua María que
recompensa iniciativas de comunidades
agrícolas del mundo entero otorgado por
la asociación de agrónomos y
veterinarios sin fronteras y para
hablarnos de todo ello hoy hacen escala
en París una de las personas
galardonadas la ecuatoriana ludmila
Vázquez Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros bienvenida
muchas gracias a ustedes por este
espacio y también está con nosotros
Federica polán que es director de esta
asociación bienvenido Y muchísimas
gracias Buenos días y muchas gracias
Bueno esta asociación de agrónomos y
veterinarios sin fronteras trabaja desde
hace mucho tiempo con comunidades
indígenas de todo el mundo es la primera
edición de este premio el premio benua
María en homenaje a este ingeniero
agrónomo francés que fue asesinado en
Guatemala el 10 de agosto de 2020 por un
grupo de personas que bueno según la
investigación ha sido una de las
hipótesis quisieron hacerle pagar un
derecho de pago esto aún no está probado
explícanos G de aquí que En qué estado
está la investigación en Guatemala y un
poco las circunstancias que se saben de
este asesinato bueno como usted lo ha
dicho el premio Benito María Viene un
poco de un drama que vivimos al interno
de nuestra asociación el asesinato de
Benito el 10 de agosto de 2020 era justo
después del periódico Benito Bueno a
María Benito para nosotros estaba
trabajando desde más de 25 años con
nosotros era nuestro representante en
Guatemala y se iba de regreso a su
trabajo después del periódico por fin
saliendo de su casa y en el camino ha
sido efectivamente un grupo de personas
le estaban esperando estaba premeditado
y le dispararon varios balas y falleció
y entonces efectivamente la justicia
guatemalteca está por el momento en
camino hay investigación en curso desde
ahora casi dos años Esperamos que nos
aportara las respuestas que su familia y
todos nosotros nuestros colegas también
esperamos efectivamente hay varias
hipótesis no sabemos todavía exactamente
Cuáles son las razones profundas de este
asesinato y si tal vez está vinculado la
acción que nuestra asociación
desarrolla en el país han apoyado a
comunidades indígenas y campesinas y
justamente para rendirle homenaje no a
adenua María a Benito María se ha creado
este premio que creo que es bianual no
se va a otorgar cada dos años y en esta
primera edición se han premiado tres
organizaciones una en Madagascar otra en
todo y otra en Ecuador
que se ha ido ese primer premio se trata
de ayo kuricancha en Ibarra en el norte
del país por un espacio de
comercialización directa entre
agricultores y consumidores que se llama
Plaza de la vida o Plaza de oro Luzmila
Vázquez que ha viajado especialmente a
Francia para para recibir este premio
explíquenos que es esa plaza de la vida
o del Oro porque en quichua me explicaba
antes Qué quiere decir oro
bueno es
nuestro espacio se llama curicancha que
que proviene de dos vocablos quichuas
Kuri que es oro y
cancha que es despacio planicie
realmente el espacio donde nosotros
estamos si vamos literalmente
este espacio debería de ser la plaza de
Plaza de oro pero para nosotros Plaza de
la vida porque ahí confluimos
productores productoras con nuestra todo
una diversidad de la producción que
hacemos en nuestras huertas en las
fincas y hacemos nuestra vida en este
espacio Ahí es donde
comercializamos de manera directa
hacemos trueque y por ello Plaza de la
vida y entre otras cosas mazorcas no que
usted dentro de toda la diversidad de
que tenemos en los en las huertas o en
las fincas tenemos nuestra base que es
el maíz que es la base alimentaria de
todas una una generación no de todos
nuestros abuelos Una alimentación básica
y cuál es la particularidad de esta
iniciativa porque la han querido
destacar por delante de otras
porque para nosotros es un perfecto
ejemplo de lo que también defendemos
como asociación es decir una agricultura
respetuosa del medio ambiente y ustedes
en Ecuador curicancha Es un grupo de
familias pioneras en agroecología no
veterinaria y al mismo tiempo sabemos
que para vivir de la agroecología hay
que comercializar también y sensibilizar
al consumidor urbano de consumir
productos buenos sanos También para su
propia salud y creo que curicancha
tuvimos 26
candidaturas elegibles al premio y
curicancha ha sido seleccionado no por
nosotros sino por un juzgado
internacional de personas independientes
de África de América Latina compañero
boliviano investigador de Francia
también y ellos seleccionaron esto por
hacer el vínculo entre producción
protección del medio ambiente consumo
sano y sensibilización de los
consumidores y a la vez también
valorización ojeva la revalorización de
estas identidades indígenas los Mila
ustedes otavalenia y entonces para
nosotros es digo un premio simbólico muy
fuerte y para la primera edición estamos
muy feliz que sakuricancha seleccionado
usted heredó de su familia una tierra de
700 metros cuadrados donde cultiva de
todo y donde también tiene animales una
tierra donde siempre se ha cultivado sin
químicos explica
pero yo he visto unas imágenes en las
que dice que bueno tras una capacitación
con
Desde esa capacitación con la asociación
agrónomos y veterinarios sin fronteras
ahora sabe lo que siembra y porque lo
siembra explíquenos
bueno
Yo realmente mi familia migró cuando yo
era niña a Quito vivimos en Quito sin
embargo después yo regresé a nuevamente
a imbabura a la zona donde se hace
producción artesanal pero también la
producción
agropecuaria digamos de granos y todo lo
que lo que se requiere para una
alimentación entonces
Bueno finalmente yo tengo un espacio en
el que igual voy sembrando de todo Tengo
este hortalizas verduras maíz plantas
medicinales plantas frutales nativas
plantas frutales de que normalmente
se comercializa en los mercados también
entonces claro para mí es es ahora
trabajar de manera más consciente
Sabiendo Por qué Y para qué lo hago en
primera instancia porque es una
alimentación sana que voy produciendo
para mi familia porque de alguna manera
yo me enfermé tuve dificultades incluso
de salud y las plantas medicinales
fueron las que me ayudaron para curar y
no así la medicina occidental me
hicieron un tratamiento de más de dos
años pero fue vano el todo ese gasto que
se hizo entonces para mí la medicina
natural la medicina que en el huerto
tenía eso es lo que lo que realmente me
curó y ese es mi enfoque también
veterinaria no No necesariamente esa es
una medicina ancestral para para los
animales Sí pero también la la misma
medicina natural las mismas plantas
medicinales tienen sus propiedades
medicinales a las personas entonces
sabemos Para qué es bueno y este mismo
estas mismas plantas las utilizamos para
la preparación de medicamentos
para prevención y curación de los
animales en especialmente Menores en mi
caso porque como tengo espacio pequeño
yo tengo cuyes gallinas patos entonces
son pequeños y ahí las aplido está muy
extendida la no veterinaria en Ecuador o
es algo marginal no bueno Quién es hemos
recibido y que estamos más conscientes
de esta situación del trabajo
sano que tenemos que producir y con la
veterinaria también generamos abono
abono fuera de químico porque con eso
alimentamos a la tierra entonces para
esa alimentación si se requiere
tener más conciencia no de lo que
estamos haciendo Y ese es el trabajo que
hago con mis animales generar abono para
alimentar a la Tierra al suelo vemos
ahora como la guerra en Ucrania federick
ha hecho que muchos granos se quedara
bloqueado y que hubiera amenazas de
hambruna en países lejanos a Ucrania la
agricultura ecológica podrá sustituir
alguna vez a esa agricultura extensiva
porque claro somos 8 millones de
personas en el mundo Entonces
efectivamente Yo sé que hay muchos
escépticos nosotros en absf pero no
solamente nosotros muchos pensamos que
sí lo podría y no es la cuestión de
sustituir una agricultura a otra sino
por lo menos ya de hacerles convivir y
de hecho esta agricultura campesina
indígena agroecológica no tienen todos
los países el soporte político
financiero que debería de tener por los
resultados que esta agricultura entonces
Obviamente si tenía estos apoyos si las
políticas públicas si los sistemas de
créditos y los sistemas de
comercialización de relación campo
ciudad estaban en su favor aquí sí esta
agricultura podría ya abastecer a un
número creciente de personas no hay que
olvidar que la agricultura campesina
ecológica ya da alimentos nosotros 70%
de nuestros alimentos a nivel mundial
provienen de pequeñas fincas
agroecológicas tal como la finca creo de
usted 70% si ponemos condiciones podemos
pasar 80 90 entonces no es de combatir o
de sacar las otras formas de agricultura
pero sí de darle un mayor espacio Cuál
es justamente el principal impedimento
para ese desarrollo en su zona del norte
de Ecuador bueno tenemos dificultades no
O sea primero que el estado no hay
ningún apoyo desde el estado hacia los
hacia los pequeños productores
no hay insumos como para apoyar a la
agroecología Entonces nosotros tenemos
que hacer los insumos para trabajar de
esta manera porque la agroecología es
una forma de vida que nuestros abuelos
hicieron y queremos seguir y no
solamente por la salud nuestra sino
también por la salud de todos los
consumidores que está alrededor nuestro
que quiere consumir sano y también
quiere tener una vida
saludable y ahí como intereses
económicos que amenazan justamente ese
modo de vida nosotros en nuestro país
una de las dificultades que tenemos son
las concesiones mineras
imbabura está denominado por la UNESCO
como geoparque mundial sin embargo tras
de eso tenemos muchas mineras en la
provincia tenemos un 30% de los de las
tierras de los productores tierras
cultivables que están concesionadas y en
otras zonas son los PE y en otros otro
tipo de cultivos Pero tenemos
dificultades de tierra de agua porque
eso está en manos de los grandes Incluso
en la en manos del mismo estado Bueno
pues ojalá se solvente en todos esos
problemas ya no nos queda más tiempo
Muchísimas gracias Luzmila Vázquez y
frederica poland por haber venido hasta
nuestros estudios Gracias y muchísimas
gracias a todos ustedes ya saben que nos
pueden seguir también por internet en rf
y mundo.com y en France 24.com Hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]